THESE COMPLAINTS?
LET'S HOPE SO.
JOHN AVLON WITH A REALITY CHECK.
>> IF YOU'RE WONDERING HOW OUR
CIVIC DEBATES SEEM TO HAVE GONE
INSANE, IT IS BECAUSE OUR
INCENTIVE STRUCTURES ARE SCREWED
UP AND TOXIC POLITICS AND SOCIAL
MEDIA ARE INTERTWINED.
THE LATEST FACEBOOK
WHISTLE-BLOWER FRANCES HAUGEN
PULLED THE CURTAIN BACK ON
INTERNAL RESEARCH SHOWING THAT
THE PLATFORM KNEW ITS ALGORITHMS
WERE AMPLIFYING DIVISION,
EXTREMISM AND POLARIZATION.
BUT THEY DID LITTLE BECAUSE THEY
WANTED TO OPTIMIZE ENGAGEMENT
AND PROFIT.
INCENTIVES.
AFTER AN ALGORITHM CHANGE IN
2018, RESEARCHERS WARNED
MISINFORMATION, VIOLENT CONTENT
ARE PREVALENT, THE TAIL WAG THE
DOG OF DEMOCRACY AT HOME AND
ABROAD.
A 2019 MEMO SHOWS THAT EUROPEAN
POLITICAL PARTIES WERE
COMPLAINING THAT THE CHANGE TO
THE ALGORITHM FORCED THEM TO
SKEW NEGATIVE IN THEIR
COMMUNICATIONS ON FACEBOOK.
LEADING THEM INTO MORE EXTREME
POSITIONS.
>> THE EUROPEAN POLITICAL
PARTIES WERE ESSENTIALLY SAYING
TO FACEBOOK THE WAY YOU HAVE
WRITTEN YOUR ALGORITHM IS
CHANGING THE WAY WE LEAD OUR
COUNTRIES.
>> YES.
YOU ARE FORCING US TO TAKE
POSITIONS THAT WE DON'T LIKE,
THAT WE KNOW ARE BAD FOR
SOCIETY.
WE KNOW IF WE DON'T TAKE THOSE
POSITIONS, WE WON'T WIN IN THE
MARKETPLACE OF SOCIAL MEDIA.
>> THE INCENTIVE STRUCTURE WAS
EFFECTIVELY FORCING POLITICAL
PARTIES TO AMPLIFY NEGATIVE
MESSAGES.
AND THE RISING CAMPAIGN ADS IN
AMERICA REFLECTS THAT DYNAMIC.
THERE HAVE BEEN FIVE OTHER
DEPARTURES OF NOBLE FACEBOOK
EMPLOYEES OVER THE PAST SEVERAL
YEARS, WARNING THE PLATFORM
FAILS TO RESPOND TO INTERNAL
WARNINGS AND IS PROFITING OFF
HATE.
THERE IS GOOD REASON FOR ALL
THIS CONCERN.
THE 2016 INTERNAL FACEBOOK
PRESENTATION OBTAINED BY THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL FRANKLY
STATED THAT 64% OF ALL EXTREMIST
GROUP JOINS ARE DUE TO OUR
RECOMMENDATION TOOLS.
THEY KNEW THAT NEO-NAZIS AND
WHITE SUPREMACISTS WERE
RECRUITING AND ORGANIZING ON
THEIR PLATFORM FOR YEARS.
WHILE FACEBOOK BELATEDLY TOOK
STEPS TO REMOVE HOLOCAUST
DENIERS AND QANON CONSPIRACY
THEORISTS, RESULTS HAVE BEEN
UNEVEN.
NOW, THIS WASN'T FACEBOOK'S
INTENTION.
IT WAS THE RESULT OF THE
INCENTIVE STRUCTURE.
AND THE BRUTAL REALITY THAT
HUMAN BEINGS ARE ATTRACTED TO
CONFLICT AND CONTROVERSY AND
ANGER.
OUR ALGORITHMS EXPLOIT THE
HUMAN BRAIN -- IF LEFT
UNCHECKED, IT WARNED FACEBOOK
USERS WOULD GET MORE AND MORE
DIVISIVE CONTENT IN AN EFFORT TO
GAIN USER ATTENTION AND INCREASE
TIME ON THE PLATFORM.
WITH GREAT POWER COMES GREAT
RESPONSIBILITY AS WE HAVE BEEN
TOLD.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT OUR LAWS
HAVE NOT KEPT PACE WITH
TECHNOLOGY AND NOW WE NEED TO
TAKE STEPS TO DEFEND OUR
DEMOCRACY.
IN SENATE TESTIMONIES SCHEDULED
TO BE GIVEN TODAY BY MISS
HAUGEN, SHE SAYS, WHEN WE
REALIZE TOBACCO COMPANIES WERE
HIDING THE HARMS IT CAUSED, THE
GOVERNMENT TOOK ACTION.
WE FIGURED OUT CARS WERE SAFER
WITH SEAT BELTS, THE GOVERNMENT
TOOK ACTION.
IMPLORE YOU TO DO THE SAME HERE.
WHAT CAN BE DONE?
FACEBOOK NEEDS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT WITH ITS DATA.
ALGORITHMS SHOULD NOT PROMOTE --
THERE SHOULD BE SAME RULES FOR
POLITICAL ADS ONLINE AS ON TV.
THIS WOULD HELP DECREASE
DISTORTION OF BOTS AND THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL IMPACT ON KIDS BY
MAKING FACEBOOK ACTUALLY ENFORCE
THEIR MINIMUM AGE REQUIREMENTS.
THERE IS NO SILVER BULLET TO
STOPPING THIS TOXIC POLARIZATION
OF OUR SOCIETY.
JAMES MADISON WARNED THAT SO
STRONG IS THE PROPENSITY OF
MANKIND TO FALL INTO MUTUAL
ANIMOSITIES, THAT THE MOST
FRIVOLOUS AND FANCIFUL
DESTRUCTIONS HAVE BEEN -- TO
EXCITE THEIR MOST VIOLENT
CONFLICTS.
SOCIAL MEDIA PUT THESE IMPULSES
ON STEROIDS.
FACEBOOK'S OWN EMPLOYEES ARE
WARNING THAT SOMETHING IS VERY
WRONG IN THE WAY SOCIAL MEDIA
PUMPS UP AND PROFITS OFF OUR